group of people from Kingman have been
arrested after the body of a 16 year old
boy was found the Mojave County
Sheriff's Office says Amber Leah
Valentine and John Imes reported their
son missing when he was actually dead
two days later Valentine called the
sheriff's office and told them that she
had just freed her 14 year old daughter
who was being held captive by the
roommates Richard pounds and shaiben
gujjda now the daughter says pounds shot
her with a BB and was abused after being
questioned about all of this Iams
admitted to deputies that he disposed of
his son's body and then lied to police
the autopsy results of the 16 year old
boy are still pending here's